Corey Lewandowski is Donald Trump's
former campaign manager he testified as
I told you in front of a House Judiciary
Committee this is being called a sort of
impeachment hearing even though it's not
really that and it's not going to lead
to impeachment and I already gave you my
criticism of the hearing itself
yesterday but today I want to talk about
the controversy over whether networks
like CNN and others should even be
willing to host Corey Lewandowski after
he testified he said during his
testimony he has no obligation to tell
the truth to the media he was
immediately booked on CNN multiple times
right after testifying that he has no
obligation to tell the truth to the
media but good for CNN host Alison
Cammarata who I believe is actually
formerly a Fox News host Corey
Lewandowski was truly embarrassed on
live television now here there's a
caveat to that word embarrassed
I don't know that Corey Lewandowski much
like Donald Trump is capable of feeling
shame so what I mean when I say he was
embarrassed is to anyone who has a
proper barometer for what should cause
one to feel shame Corey Lewandowski was
embarrassed on live television by Alison
cammarata I think if you ask him he
won't feel any shame I don't think he's
he's able to feel that he tried the no
collusion no obstruction line this is a
talking point that all of these trumpets
have been using since the Moller report
came out and Alison camerata says no no
no that is not what the Moller report
said and then it's immediately revealed
that Corey Lewandowski hasn't even read
the Moller report he's lecturing Alison
Camerata on what's in the Moller report
even though he hasn't read it here's
something here's the first clip it's a
it's really entertaining so you
confirmed that you were asked to
obstruct justice
no I awesome please it's not what I
confirmed at all by the way the Muller
report was very clear there was no
collusion there was no obstruction
absolutely says that you should read
page you should read the page at that
states and Bob wait a second hold on a
second hold on a second timeout timeout
did you read them all a report no I
never did and how do you know what it
says because the members of Congress
were very clear about what was in that
report yesterday and so I'm real right
now there's no Christ
sorry did your report have you read the
report read the entire report Cori of
course I had to read the entire report
and let me tell you what it said so
there were ten different examples of
obstruction of justice it's not what it
said did it did not say there were ten
example of ten examples of obstruction
Allison you're being disingenuous Cori
of course Allison camerota is correct I
believe there were fourteen possible
obstructive acts of which there were
three requirements were met on I believe
it's eight eight of the fourteen
obstructive acts and it's interesting
that corey lewandowski is choosing to
use the word disingenuous there's this
Trump astute all's into my show named
Jimmy from Philly and he'll call in when
I take live calls and he every time I
say something he doesn't like her or
agree with he says I'm being
disingenuous this has become almost like
a reflexive meme for trumpets where if
you call someone disingenuous they
circumvent having to discuss the actual
truth or falsity of anything just by
saying the person is being disingenuous
and therefore they don't deserve to be
listened to that's exactly what Corey
Lewandowski is trying to do here and I'd
love to say Wow Alison camerata really
did something amazing here this is just
basic journalism it's just happening so
infrequently that in a way we've become
unaccustomed to it but this is exactly
the way that these lie I mean he
admitted that he lies to media during
his hearing under oath let's take a look
at how it continued he seems to say okay
those are obstructive acts but that
didn't come from the Moller report which
of course it did here we go to let the
Flynn investigation go when he tried to
stop sessions recusal that's the one
that you were involved in you may want
to read that part when he fired call me
when the president tried to remove
Muller when the president tried to get
sessions to limit the probe that's
another one you were involved in when he
obscured the purpose of the Trump Tower
meeting when he asked sessions to
reverse his refusal asking McGann to
deny attempts to remove Muller trying to
influence cooperation of witnesses
including Flynn man for Dan Cohen those
are just some of the examples that
scores of
legal experts say our obstruction of
justice how can legal experts make a
determination when they're unfamiliar
with all the facts of the case that's a
that is so disingenuous to go and make a
predetermination as a quote legal expert
without having the opportunity to hear
both sides of the case there it is again
disingenuous attacking the character and
motives of people because you don't like
the facts that they're presenting you to
you what is even talking about people
who haven't heard the facts the Muller
report said that the threshold for
obstruction was met on eight of those
possible obstructive acts let's look at
just a little bit more of this how is
that not a predetermination against this
president because it's less worried it
lays it out in the more of the examples
that any regular citizen would have been
charged and convicted of if they were
not a sitting US president you know that
part right I don't know that to be true
what I do know is that Attorney General
bar is the Deputy Attorney General of
the United States decided that there was
no obstruction and I believe an attorney
general bar unless you're saying that
Attorney General bar is not a qualified
competent individual that he and the
Deputy Attorney General this is a
technique that they love you aren't
saying that William bar is unqualified
or incompetent are you Allison cammarata
but the issue was never qualifications
or competency with William Bar its that
bar is compromised bar is partial bar is
biased and he was brought in
specifically as the hatchet man to
prevent anything from moving forward on
the off chance that there was the
possibility of any kind of charge
against the president moving forward and
the question I have for you is after
looking at this and after seeing corey
lewandowski testify that he doesn't have
to tell the truth to media outlets and
regularly doesn't as we found out my
question to you is should CNN keep
booking habitual persistent
uncontrollable malignant liars like
Corey Lewandowski because on the one
hand
you are legitimizing their lying by
booking them after they say under oath I
lie to the media all the time and then
you reward them by giving them more
publicity and booking them on your
channel on the other hand the
counter-argument would be Allisyn
cammarata did make Corey Lewandowski
look really dumb here and maybe there is
something to be gained some net benefit
from exposing them in this way I'm
opening up the question to you let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and this seems actually like
a really great topic for an upcoming
twitch stream please follow me at twitch
TV
David Pakman if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription already you can subscribe
free to you to my twitch channel with
twitch prime costs you nothing but it
counts as a paid subscription for me
twitch.tv slash David Pakman I want to
tell you about one of our sponsors
called the Menlo Club immense fashion
community that provides carefully
curated style packages for any type of
guy and they're giving you as a David
Pakman show viewer your first box for
$35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of two items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription
anytime right now I am on their monthly
subscription for 60 bucks a month but
they also offer a seasonal subscription
where they send you a box of clothing
every three months for just 75 bucks but
regardless of which option you choose
they are giving everyone in our audience
$35 off their first box to redeem your
$35 discount just click the link under
this video or go to their website and
use the promo code Pakman at checkout